because academically
yeah and currently he's a professor of
philosophy at NYU and has published a
variety of influential works in
philosophy of physics including several
books his first book quantum mechanics
and quantum nonlocality and relativity
is really a classic it's just been
published in a third edition recently
he's also written on a book on truth and
paradox the metaphysics within physics
and more recently there's two volumes
that I think only the first volume has
appeared on philosophy of physics from
the Princeton foundations of philosophy
series and most recently there's new
foundations for physical geometry which
has just appeared in print so we're
really it's really a great thrill to
have Tim speaking on the geometrical
structure in the direction of time thank
you so this is gonna be I mean fasten
your seat belts I've got 25 slides for
everyone David showed this should take
two hours to do and I'm gonna try and
get through let me talk a little bit
about foreground some some of our
disagreements maybe in a way that will
be helpful
David had remembered this geometry up
there so there's a certain point where
he's talking about geometrical structure
of the arena and he gets down to a point
where it admits of no further analysis
okay so you get a fundamental structure
and what he actually had in there was a
topological structure are three I'm
going to talk about that in a minute so
this is really going to be a partly a
talk about the whole question of how do
we decide what should be fundamental in
what should be derived and what do we do
once we've made that decision about our
accounts of the things now clearly we
want to say our physical theories are
committed to certain ontology xand it
should be lots of things right I mean a
physical on top and some sense physics
ought to be committed to ontology which
includes this building because we think
it's a physical object and so you could
say the ontology if here is just
everything it's committed to their being
facts about or something like that but
that's a little vague so take for
example the center of mass of the solar
system to some extent you'd say there
a fact about what it is at least
classically don't worry about quantum
mechanics and it does something it's
always somewhere and it moves but or is
it really part of what the theory is
committed to in its ontology and what
really exists my center of mass doesn't
really exist and if you went there in
space and looked there you wouldn't see
anything so that obviously suggests just
making a distinction here and saying
yeah in some sense or other the center
of mass is real but we want to demote it
and say in another sense it's derivative
okay it's not a fundamental thing and in
that case it's easy to see it's not
fundamental because we define it in
terms of the positions and masses of all
these other planets and and the Sun that
in a more direct sense are where they're
supposed to be so you would say the
masses and positions of the parts of the
solar system are more fundamental than
the center of mass good so that means
there are some things we define in terms
of other things and there's going to be
a hierarchy of definition and this goes
back to Aristotle if we wanted to get
into it and obviously as we work our way
down this hierarchy of definitions we
can we can take terms that we've used
for designing them for defining some
things and in turn define them in terms
of something else and but eventually
that has to end right eventually the
project of explicate iliza in terms of
something else has to give out and so
you get down to some fundamental level
where there is no such kind of
exploitation available all right and in
a certain sense you want to say it's
these bottom level objects that are the
fundamental things that exist and in
virtue of this hierarchy of definitions
then the other derived things exist but
you understand how their existence
depends upon the fundamental things now
where do we end right what we have to
make a decision about where this attempt
to explicate things in terms of other
things comes to an end now I happen to
be have staked a bunch of positions that
go by the name of primitivism because
they're basically saying for certain
sorts of things that that philosophers
have taken
a lot of trouble to try and analyze just
stop right this is this is the sort of
thing you ought to expect this
fundamental you does not admit of any
further analysis so I hold this position
about laws I don't think that there's an
analysis of what a law of nature is in
terms of some other kind of thing I what
what I'm going to be talking about today
is the direction of time and that's how
it connects up a bit with this idea of
are we trying to explain mechanically or
otherwise the directionality of time or
are we gonna take it as fundamental let
me just say what do we do I mean if I
can't explicate something by analysis
because it's fundamental how do I let
you know what it means how do I make it
clear what I'm talking about and
obviously it just goes the other
direction on one hand I try and
represent its structure as well as I can
but the more important thing is I
explain other things in terms of it okay
and that's how I get a grasp of what it
is so how does this go in terms of
geometry what is the basic level of
geometrical structure that we want to
postulate that has no further analysis
in terms of anything else now as it
turns out if you just think about a
space like Euclidean space it has lots
of different geometrical structure to it
and even those pieces of geometrical
structure have a different kind of
hierarchy in that some presuppose others
that is in explicate assuming some
others are in place so take for example
the notion of the distance between two
points you know Euclidean space I might
say there's some distance between two
points how do i that actually is
something that is subject to definition
as say the length of the shortest or I
put longest because in relativity we
actually be using the longest path
continuous path between the points so I
I think here my two points a and B now
there are all of these possible ways of
continuously getting from A to B and
each of these continuous paths has a
length and I can then pick the shortest
length and call that the distance right
so there's an example of analyzing the
distance in terms of something else but
obviously in order for that definition
to work I already need to
that there's something that counts as
can all the continuous paths between a
and B and something that counts as their
length I need to give an analysis of the
notion of length which on this way of
explicate ins turns out to be more
fundamental but it doesn't go the other
way around that is the notion of a
continuous path does not in in turn
appeal to any notion of distance so I
can give an account of what it is for a
path from A to B T to be continuous
without mentioning distances or lengths
or anything like that so you see a kind
of definitional asymmetry here which
tells us which level is going to have to
sit below which level in this
definitional structure now if we think
of geometry as it is presently done we
have the metrical structure distance
structure below that there's a less
detailed structure which is essentially
ways of picking out straight lines from
curved lines that's called the affine
structure there's below that another
level of structure called the Divi
amorphic structure which can distinguish
lines that are sort of smooth from those
that are bent but there's a bottom level
there is a sort of the level beneath
which there is nothing else and we it is
called topology now one way that
topology is commonly described as as
rubber sheet geometry so it's a nice
image you imagine drawing some designs
on a rubber sheet and then pulling it
and deforming it as you pull it and
deform it clearly distances between
points will change straight lines will
be turned into curved lines and so on so
various geometrical features will not be
preserved under these deformations but
certain fet geometrical facts will
continue to hold so a continuous path
from A to B if I deform the rubber sheet
will still be a continuous path from A
to B right so we can ask about what are
the geometrical characteristics that are
invariant under these sorts of under
these sorts of transformations really
there's nothing in standard geometry
that sits below the topological
structure the so you can think of
topological structure as the thing that
defines continuity in this space
and I basically presuppose that's
already there before I go about trying
to give you anything more now all right
what determines that right we keep
working our way down if that's what
topology is about what fixes the
topology of a space now there's a
standard answer to this so this is what
you'll go over to the math department it
called point-set topology and the
standard answer is that the basic
concept the concept that doesn't get
explicate ydynt IRMS of any others is
that of an open set and so if you
imagine starting out with a collection
of points and wanting to organize them
into a space because a collection of
points just on their own don't form a
space they're just a set right they have
a cardinality there'd be a certain
number of them but if they're just the
collection they don't have any geometry
the way I specify the topology is by
saying which subsets of this collection
are the open sets right so I put a
geometry on my set of points by putting
an open set structure on it and I put an
open set structure on it just by
indicating one way or another which
collections of points constitute open
sets and then then there are a whole lot
of others geometrical features of the
space that I define in terms of the open
set structure and the the list is very
very long of defined terms that if you
just fix the T'Pau it fix the open sets
you'll now give give you facts about
whether the space is connected it'll
tell you whether certain functions from
one space to another continuous
functions it'll tell you about the
boundary of a set so here's the sort of
architecture of standard topology
sitting at the bottom or the open sets
now it turns out these are inter
definable with the closed sets in the
neighborhoods anybody who knows this
stuff will be familiar these are all
interdependent
then I have a bunch of definitions that
will tell me okay
now if you give me this information I'll
tell you whether your space is connected
I'll tell you which points are on the
boundary of a set I'll tell you whether
a function from one part of this space
to another is a continuous function I
can define a curve which
a continuous function from the real line
into his space now you see how the words
continuous function appear there so I
have to have defined continuous function
to define a curve and a path is an image
of a curve that is it's the set of
points that that if I the idea of a
curve is that I've got the real line
here the set of real numbers and I have
a function continuous function into my
space and as I run down the real line I
get an image over here and that image
will be a curved path so that's the
architecture of standard topology and
you run down here to the bottom now what
kind of grip do we get on what what do
we mean by an open set
what is that trying to get at well if
you open at any introductory topology
book before it gets to this to the real
formal definition it will give you an
informal explication it'll give you
images like the rubber sheet geometry
image which give you a sense of what
we're trying to get at when we say that
a set is open and so here a couple ways
that are done this is one standard
introduction by crosley an open set is
one at what every point has some
breathing space right so the picture is
in an open set every point in the open
set is completely surrounded by other
points in the set right so if you're a
point you can just take a deep breath
and sort of expand out a little bit in
every direction you can expand out in
and you're still inside the set right
you're not if you were sitting on the
boundary you just couldn't go off in a
certain direction at all without
dropping out of the set or if you if you
don't want to know I said if you don't
want to know it's true but you want to
know what people think you go to
Wikipedia and when I first wrote this
this was what it's changed now but this
is when I first wrote my book this is
one Wikipedia which I like in topology
and related fields of mathematics the
set U is called open if intuitively
speaking you can wiggle or change any
point X and you buy a small amount in
any direction and still be inside you in
other words X is surrounded only by
elements of you it can't be on the edge
of U that is U has no edge okay now if
you think about this again this is not a
formal definition why because your
explicate inist in terms of something
else in this case wiggling or changing
in any amount in any direction there's a
bunch of concepts that are in that so
this is just to give you a feeling for
what we're trying to define formally but
since I can't define my fundamental
notions in terms of anything else how do
I get a grip on them right I can't the I
can't actually take this seriously well
I only have one choice I have to as it
were define my fundamental notions by in
terms of themselves that is by putting
structural constraints on the
fundamental thing and this is what's
done in standard topology so you have
some axioms and you say if you want to
tell me that a collection of subsets of
points are the open sets in a space they
have to and this is all they have to do
they have to obey these axioms any
collection of subsets that obeys all the
axioms is an OK topology and here the
rules the whole said it's going to be an
open set the empty set has to be an open
set if you have any collection of open
sets and union them together that's got
to be an open set and if you have a
finite collection of open sets and take
their intersections that's got to be an
open set and any collection that
satisfies all four rules is good enough
it counts as a topology and then once
you've specify the open sets in terms of
this structure of definitions I can now
tell you a whole lot about the geometry
of your space now I think this whole
thing was a mistake okay I mean I think
the entire thing from beginning to end
is wrong because they picked the wrong
fundamental notion to define all right
so what I've been doing for a long time
is producing an alternative way of doing
all of this and it's actually going to
turn out to connect up to our issue
about time
if you hang with me we'll get there so
if I'm not gonna use open sets what am I
going to use I'm gonna use lines I'm
gonna use the idea the fundamental idea
the fundamental concept that's not
defined in terms of anything else but is
rather nailed down by a set of axioms is
going to be the idea of a line a
one-dimensional line more particularly
an open line in the sense that it
doesn't close back on itself so not like
a circle but a line that that doesn't
self intersect I don't care whether it
has endpoints or not it could have two
endpoints it could have one
pointing could have no end points but an
open line in that sense what's
characteristic about that kind of thing
what makes it really geometrically
special is that on an open line like
that if I pick any two points there is a
definite and only unique way to get from
one point to the other while staying on
the line while moving continuously right
if I have a circle and I pick these two
points I could go either clockwise or
counterclockwise but what that means is
that there's a very strong structural
constraint that can be written down
about what a set of points has to be in
order to be aligned the other thing
about lines it's really nice is that
long lines have shorter lines as parts
right long lines are actually made up of
lines whereas open sets don't have to be
if you go back to that set of
definitions you can have an open set
with an infinite number of points and
absolutely none of its subsets are open
okay so open sets aren't made out of
smaller open sets but long lines are and
have to be made out of shorter lines so
this puts another another nice
analytical place where we can get a grip
on our definitions to characterize what
we mean okay and what really happens is
that in an open line you represent the
structure by ordering the points it's
represented by a linear order among the
points so you know if I start here in
the line imagine you've got even you can
also do this it doesn't matter if it's
continuous in the sense of like the real
line if you imagine a line of moviegoers
right waiting for tickets they can form
a line but again you have an ordering of
them so this one then that one then that
one you can say of any two which ones
are between okay so the linear order now
this is a so here's going to be our new
architectural structure we're going to
have the line sitting at the bottom in
terms of the lines we're going to define
all these other things now this funny
font is my font which means those are my
words which means they mean what I say
they mean and it turns out that I'm
going to give you definitions of the
same sounding concepts like what a
connected space is or what a
neighborhood is or what a continuous
function is but my definitions won't
even be materially the same as a
standard definition so certain spaces
that count is connected on the standard
definitions don't count as connect
mine certain functions that count as
continuous in the standard way or not
continuous according to me and so on
alright and so I'm gonna define the
lines in terms of that I'm gonna find
the neighborhoods and then way up here
sitting at the top I'm gonna define some
open sets they're actually two
alternative but equivalent ways to
define the open sets that's that's the
scheme so let me just give you a sense
of this I said the the main thing about
a line is that the or the points in it
are linearly ordered and this is if
you've ever done this you'll just
remember it if not pretend this is what
a linear order is it's a relation that
like greater than or equal that has the
following feet three characteristics its
anti-symmetric so if P and Q if it holds
between P and Q in both ways and P and Q
are the same element its transitive so
if P is greater than or equal to Q and Q
is greater than or equal to R then P is
greater than or equal to R and it's
total than that for any pair of points
one or the other of those holes so
that's just what a linear order is and
if you have a linear order on a set you
can define an interval this was a
definition as far as I know invented by
data can because if you have a linear
order if you pick any two points it's
well-defined which other points lie
between and so an interval is just a set
of points such that for any pair of
points in it all the ones in between
them are in it so there are no gaps in
that sense you don't skip over anything
so that's a night that's gonna be really
useful for us so now I'm going to do
exactly play exactly the same game as
standard topology I'm going to give you
some axioms and that the lines have to
satisfy so you'll actually specify the
linear structure of a space by telling
me which collections of points
constitute lines and they have to
satisfy these axioms so the first one's
really simple a line contains at least
two points this one the segment axiom is
in an official sense the entire theory
because the other ones I if you just
give me this there's a unique way to
expand the set so it satisfies the two
other axioms that are remaining so we're
not going to spend a lot of time on them
and the segment axiom is exactly this
idea that lines are made of shorter
lines like longer lines are made of
so if I have a bunch of points and it's
a line I must be able to put a linear
order among those points such that the a
part of that is itself aligned if and
only if it's an interval in that linear
order so it's a necessary and sufficient
condition for a part of a line to itself
be a line that there there has to be a
single linear there has to be a linear
order I can put on these such that all
and only its intervals are themselves
lines and that's you know the the way
lines relate to each other as
part-to-whole now that's taking lines
taking a long line and picking shorter
lines out of it there's another axiom
which has to do with taking two lines
and putting them together so if I have a
line from A to B and a line from B to C
intuitively if I Union them together I
have a line from A to C I have to there
has to be a little but you don't want to
make a circle or have the thing self
intersects so there's a little provision
in here and I don't even want to talk
about that one but if you give me a set
of points a set of a proposed set of
lines that satisfies just the second
axiom there's a unique way working from
that to generate a thing that satisfies
all four now notice I said in a line
there has to be a linear order there if
you get all the points on the line you
must be able to order them in some way
so that all and only the intervals in
that order or themselves lines it's easy
to see that if there's one linear order
that does that there's exactly one other
namely the opposite one so you could
imagine going right to left or going
left to right right I can I can ABC or I
can go ABC this way those two linear
orders and only those two linear orders
have exactly the same set of intervals
so if there is one way of linear
ordering them that works there is
exactly one other good now let me give
you an idea so here's a space these
things are the points these don't
represent anything except that these
pair of points constitute a line so this
is a minimal line it's only
two points and that just there's nothing
more in here and given that and given
the the splicing axiom if this is a line
and this is a line it'll turn out that
those two together have to be aligned so
you can get all the lines off of this by
starting anywhere and always moving to
an adjacent point and just be making
sure you never close down right so so
all of the sets along this red path or
law constitute a line but I can't add
this one because I would get a closed
loop and that would violate one of my
conditions so it's sort of easy to see
what the lines are on a square lattice
given the lines I can define the
neighborhood's
a set Sigma is a neighborhood of a point
P what's the idea of a neighborhood the
idea is I've got a point
a neighborhood completely surrounds it a
neighborhood completely protects it from
attack on all sides a neighborhood of
the point means I can't get to that
point from outside without first
entering the neighborhood okay
and that's what this definition tells
you it tells you if I have a line that
ends at P then it's got a segment if
that line has a little part of it that
is itself a line that sits inside the
neighborhood so this is the natural
definition of a neighborhood in this way
of teasing things out and so on the
square lattice the four red points
together with the yellow point
constitute a neighborhood of the yellow
point because obviously if I start out
here and I want to get to the yellow
point I have to enter the neighborhood
first there'll be a little final line
that sits in there good now that I have
defined a neighborhood I can define an
open set an open set a set as open if
it's a neighborhood of all its members
well that's just we said we said in an
open set every point is completely
surrounded by other points in the set
right that was the informal definition
you were given of course that's not the
way it's played out in the standard
thing but that's actually what you do
here because opens the open sets are
actually defined you can actually put
constructive definition that looks like
your informal definition it actually
looks like the definition you would find
in standard topology using their notion
of a neighborhood rather than mine but
their notion is different than mine so
it's not the same as the same
definition good having done all that the
picture now is you give me a set of
points I put a linear structure on it I
specify the lines that specifies the
neighborhoods that specifies the open
sets so by investing a set of points
with a linear structure I automatically
invested with a standard topology in
fact I can prove that the open sets as
I've defined them will always satisfy
the four axioms of standard topology
okay so all the resources of standard
topology are already going to be
available to you but there's a lot more
geometrical information contained in the
linear structure in the set of lines
than there is in the open set structure
and then you can actually play with this
right so you say all right give me five
points to play with how many different
topology standard topologies can I put
on my set of five points it's about
seven thousand how many different linear
structures can I define on my set of
five points only about a thousand each
of those linear structures generates a
topology but many of them generate the
same topology so out of the seven
thousand topologies only 52 arise in
this way from an underlying linear
structure now I was pretty happy about
this when I first discovered cuz I
thought you know there are some
topologies and standard topologies that
that you can define and we can write
them down and you can analyze them but
you I couldn't understand them I
couldn't I couldn't picture in my head
what exactly is this space right what is
the geometry that you're trying to
convey to me with this so I came up at
that point with the term of a
geometrically uninterpretable topology
which is a topology that can't be
generated from an underlying set of
lines and I said gee look it turns out
most standard topologies just aren't
geometrically interpreted
that's why I can't understand them well
that wasn't that was an interesting idea
lasted a little while right it suggested
it suggested this that that's why you're
so confused when you do standard
topology sometimes
but what happened was I thought about
this for a while and then something
occurred to me and all of this is now
going to so let me give you an idea take
the simplest interesting case I got two
points and I want to put a geometry on
them I want to make them into a space if
I'm doing what I'm doing my only choices
are there any lines here or not now
remember every line has to contain at
least two points so my only question is
do those two points form a line or not
that's the only choice I have if they
don't then that generates this topology
where every set is an open set and if
they do then it generates this topology
where the only open sets are the empty
set in the whole space
the original axioms if you remember of
standard topology require that the empty
set always be open in the whole space be
open in the industry so-called industry
topology those are the only open sets in
the discrete topology every set is open
which will easily satisfy all the axioms
so those always exist so the idea was
look those are the only two geometries
you can make out of a pair of points
however standard topology allows you to
do something else so standard topology
allows you to put a topology here where
say the empty set is open the whole
space is open just the unit set
containing P is open but the unit set
containing Q isn't and if you go back
and revisit the original axioms you'll
see that choice also would satisfy the
original the original axioms
that's called a sierpinski space and
that was the kind of space when I would
sort of say I don't understand that
space right what magic pixie dust if you
if if this thing is open and this thing
isn't what magic pixie dust did you
sprinkle on the point P that gave it
that characteristic right what is the
geometry you're trying to convey to me I
don't get it so I was kind of happy
about this then I thought a little more
and I thought well wait a minute and
remember the idea was back here let me
go back here for a second in an open set
if you start in the set you can't wiggle
you're any small wiggle will keep you in
the set and by us
small wiggle here we mean moving along
the line so that's why the set just
containing P here is not open because if
I start in it I can wiggle my way out
and that's why all the sets here are
open because if I start in them I can't
go anywhere there are no lines there's
nowhere to go I'm just stranded wherever
I start okay so then I thought well but
wait a minute we could do something else
here if we want to understand these this
idea of openness in terms of Wiggles
we've been thinking of the lines as
two-way streets we've been thinking of
the lines and if I can get along a line
from A to B I can always go back from B
to a right but why do I require that
this is associated with the thing I
pointed out a while ago that if one
linear order has this set of intervals
the converse one will as well right so
there were two linear orders that would
represent any single line so then you
have the thought well what if I just say
no I'm going to put a direction on my
lines I'm going to give them an
intrinsic directionality a
directionality that doesn't arise from
anything else okay
let's treat the lines as one-way streets
right so I have an open line but in
addition I have a directionality on it
now that direction a letís not derived
from anything else okay so this is
fundamental we were talking about
fundamental and derivative here there's
gonna be a fundamental feature of my
lines now I'm going to give them a
directionality and when I talk about a
small wiggle or a continuous motion
along the line I mean in the direction
that's indicated and then we get the
idea of a directed linear structure okay
we just modify the axioms and we require
all of our lines to have a direction and
we make there there are some little
adjustments obvious adjustments to the
axioms like if I'm splicing two lines
together they need to match in direction
so I need if the line goes from A to B
and the arrows that way and from B to C
and the arrows that way that I can
splice them together smoothly now with
my two points I have four choices right
I can have no lines at all I can have a
line from P to Q line from Q to P or two
lines one from P to Q and one from Q to
P plug all this into my definitions I
will now generate four
you all of the standard topologies but
now I understand them right so I said
before what magic pixie does did I
sprinkle on key to make that an open set
and the answer is because look if you
start at key you can't wiggle your way
out from P right but if I start from Q I
can so the directionality exactly
explains that what it tells you is that
most thought of this way most standard
topologies have an intrinsic
directionality in them but you couldn't
see it you couldn't understand it you
couldn't identify it because if I asked
you to put a direction on a line you
know what to do and if I asked you to
put a direction on an open set you don't
know what to do okay there just wouldn't
convey anything to you mathematically or
any other way what would it even mean
good so now we adjust it this way now we
can redo our calculations and it's sort
of cute things happens so if we go back
down to having only five points to play
with we now have over a million directed
linear structures and from those million
you generate every single one of the
standard ones so the whole thing flips
around in a certain way and in fact you
can prove another theorem which is that
if you will only finitely many points
every single standard topology you can
generate from an underlying linear
structure okay these this is an example
of two obviously different geometries
that generate the same open set
structure right obviously different and
this one to get from you can get from P
to Q but you've got to go through R and
in this one you can get from P to Q
directly right so these are just
different geometries but if I put on the
lenses of standard topology and said
just tell me about the open sets the
only open sets here are the empty set in
the whole space so standard topology
would not be able to distinguish them
all right so now we have this structure
now what what David said about his earth
space if we go back what David said
about his earth space was it had a
topology the topology of RN which is
given in a standard way by the set of a
collection of open sets that are just
like those in a Euclidean n-dimensional
space and that idea that when you do
spate when you're trying to
represent mathematically represent
space-time geometry you start with a
topological manifold you start with a
set of points with a topology already on
it and that topology does not come from
anywhere so if you're doing general
relativity and you're gonna build a
mathematical model of a possible
space-time you go to the closet and you
pull a four dimensional manifold out off
the shelf okay that's what you start
with why why should afford now this is
this is what you do mathematically is
that really motivated should we think
that space-time fundamentally at this
most basic level has the same
geometrical structure as a four
dimensional Euclidean space so one of my
thoughts is that the reason people keep
saying physics has turned time into just
another dimension right is because
they're using a mathematics which is
treating them all of these things as if
it was just another spatial dimension
right it's built into the mathematics
that they're using but it's really
unmotivated if you think in terms of
lines it's completely unmotivated so let
me explain what I mean right
why should a four dimensional manifold a
foot a thing that looks like Euclidean
space at this fundamental structure be
the right thing to represent space and
time together so in Euclidean space okay
we have all these first of all in
Euclidean space you think there are no
directed lines any line that you can
travel one way you can travel back along
the other way why it's why have two two
arrows there and you can imagine in this
three-dimensional space all the
continuous lines there are they go all
every which way
now when we look at time space time when
we look at the geometry of space and
time together and we represent it in the
way we do mathematically for classical
theories this is what it looks like
there is a dimension this is the one
David was picking out with his double
use a dimension we call time there is a
foliation that is you split your
space-time up into these sheets whereas
intuitively these are all the events
that happen at one time these are all
the events that happen at a later time
and so on
now if you if you're putting all this
down on top of a four dimensional
manifold and you think gee though the
lines in this space are just like a
Euclidean four dimensional space then
you would get lines like this you get
lines like this one that look it goes up
through time and then for awhile it's
completely spatial and then it becomes
goes through time again and this one is
always progressing through time this one
is always completely confined to a
particular moment this one turns around
in time somehow bounces around in time
those are really weird right that is
this is this could be the trajectory of
a particle that's fine and that might
represent instantaneously a measuring
rod at one moment that's fine but there
is nothing in physics that ever uses
anything like that and there's nothing
in physics that ever uses anything like
that so why should we think they're
there why should we think they're
actually part of the space-time geometry
now when we go to relativity we get rid
of that foliation we get rid of that
time that absolute time structure this
was actually part of what David built
into time was that it gives you a
foliation that's not built into my
notion of time at all I'm perfectly
happy with time and relativity what's
built into relativity fundamentally is a
light cone structure and the light at
every event there's a future and past
light cone that divides up the rest of
the manifold in a certain way and again
in relativity this thing might represent
the trajectory of a particle this just
wouldn't correspond to anything physical
nothing physical is ever gonna do that
and nothing physical is ever going to do
that so why think those lines are even
there in the geometry we don't need them
we don't really even want them if you go
into Bob Wald's general relativity book
he talked about curves like the one that
I have that changed from time life to
space like so they sort of changed from
going vertically to horizontally and he
says their length is not defined we
can't even define what we would mean by
the length of such a line for
mathematical reasons so the question is
why don't we get rid of them right let's
throw them away if we're thinking in
terms of fundamental lines
okay then we ought to just eliminate
certain things now the claim is that we
now think of the fundamental geometry of
space-time in terms of these lines if
we're doing relativity and this is not
true if we're doing classical physics we
can even ask a deeper question because
we're always asking can I give a further
explanation when do I hit the bottom of
my account can I imagine a physical
feature of the universe that even
generates these lines can I imagine a
physical feature of the universe that
accounts for the existence of these arms
what that what we're doing is then
asking because what the points are now
events the points are space-time points
is there a physical feature of the
universe that generates a linear order
among the points of space-time because
that's the essence of a line is a linear
order among its points right now as it
turns out if you ask yourself even
before you heard anything I said today
is there any feature of the physical
universe that puts an order on the
following pair of events okay it would
not take you long to say sure there is
an ordering there there is the ordering
of before and after one happened earlier
in time and the later of the other later
what we always thought what we thought
from the beginning is that time itself
what it fundamentally does is order
events by an asymmetric relation of
before and after and so we can ask maybe
we can now understand the geometry of
space-time in terms of this ordering
just the time ordering now I can do this
in classical physics and it doesn't work
so let me just explain why so suppose I
wanted to try and define the fundamental
geometry in completely temporal terms
here's the thought you say well give me
a set of points a maximal set of events
so I can't add any more to this set and
have the same structure a maximal set of
events that are linearly ordered in time
so for every pair of events there's a
fact
about which come first and which comes
later right and I do that in classical
physics I do that in in I guess I
thought alright sorry I guess I thought
I had a picture that I don't have
thought of god no so I have what
remember I had this foliation of the
space-time in two moments here all the
events that happened now and later all
this is asking for is that every moment
pick a point at every moment pick a
point and generically that set of points
will look like a random scatter I mean
the points will just jump around they
won't look like anything continuous but
if I do the very same thing if I try the
same thing in relativity in particular
if I restrict myself to globally
hyperbolic space times and I asked give
me a maximal set of events the set of
events I can't add any to that are all
linearly ordered in time so for any pair
of these events there's a fact about
which came first and which came later
and what you will get what someone would
normally say is what you'll get is a
continuous curve that everywhere is
either time like or no so you'll
actually generate just by a completely
temporal criterion a natural-looking
linear directed linear structure a
linear structure on these points and
furthermore an asymmetric one because
time is doing all the work okay so why
is that so I pick here's gonna be a
point in my set that means the next
point I pick can't be out here and it
can't be out here because it has to have
a definite time relation to this event
and the only events with definite time
relation to this event are either in its
past or future light cone
so I'm now restricted so now suppose I
pick the Green Point alright that's fine
it's in the future of the red point but
now for points between red and green I'm
further restricted because they have to
sit in the future light cone of red and
in the past light cone of green right so
I've restricted even further and if you
sort of carry out what these
restrictions mean they're going to give
you sets of events that look like
continuous curves through space-time
so if this is a picture from one of
Shawn Carroll's books and just to give
you an idea when he's explaining
relativity he's got the light cones and
he says a timelike path is allowed what
he means is allowed for a particle a
part of the mic have that as its
trajectory but he says a space-like path
is not allowed now I want to say it's
not just that it's not allowed it said
it doesn't exist there is no such thing
in the fundamental geometry so that
means the the even David's choice of an
or geometry right he chose as his air
geometry a four dimensional man or an N
dimensional manifold I would say that's
the wrong choice I would say that's not
actually the geometry even at that most
fundamental level that's not the
geometry of space-time the geometry of
space-time is what you're going to get
by following the recommendation I get so
if you do this remember the basic
relation the ordering relation that
we're using here is an asymmetric one
it's before-and-after right and to say
that P occurs before Q is different from
saying that P occurs after Q right I
mean the order in which things go it's
not like sibling hood right if a and B
are siblings and B and a or siblings
fine
it's an asymmetric relation and that a
symmetric relation reflects the
fundamental directionality of time now I
think this is a really nice place to go
fundamental I think this is a really
nice place to say we should stop here we
shouldn't try and give a further
explanation or account of the direction
of time the direction of time if you see
it playing this role which you can only
see through this particular lens of a
mathematical theory is doing a job right
that doesn't need anything underneath it
to further produce it and furthermore
the other thing about taking the
direction of time all right
so this is where I think we ought to end
at the at this asymmetric before/after
relation and from that ordering you then
can define addressing linear structure
and from that you derive the whole
light-cone structure of the space you
can drive almost almost all the geometry
of a relativistic space not quite you
need a metric but you get the light-cone
structure out of this and there's no
attempt to reduce or analyze the basic
asymmetry to anything else right it is
the fundamental ordering principle now
let me just say one more because I'm
gosh I did this in 45 minutes
good lord okay let me just say one more
thing because David said something
surprised me a little bit because we're
coming up to have this discussion about
what he meant by a mechanical
explanation and he explained what he
meant by a mechanical explanation I have
nothing wrong with his explanation it's
it is to my ears not what was usually
meant by a mechanical explanation so
when people said of Newton look Newton's
defined a clockwork universe and there's
a kind of mechanical account of how
everything happens and everything's like
a fancy Swiss clock right that was your
example of a mechanic's writes all cogs
and wheels and things bumping into other
things and moving them around that kind
of mechanical explanation I claim so not
the one David defined but the one that
would might jump to your mind that kind
of mechanical explanation presupposes a
direction of time right because the
story you tell is of earlier things
bumping into things and and creating the
future by those interactions I mean one
might say to put it another way if you
take David's example of a bunch of
billiard balls bouncing around on a
billiard table and you ask how did ball
five come to be here right now I think
most people would accept is a mechanical
explanation a story of the history of
collisions among the balls that read up
from before then to now but I think most
people would not accept as a mechanical
explanation if I took the later states
and
retro dicted now it's true the later
states and the laws can tell me us you
know can tell me where the ball was at
an earlier time but I think most people
wouldn't think of that as a mechanical
explanation of how it got to be there
they would say okay that's giving me
information that it was there what's the
difference well the difference is before
and after play a fundamental role in our
concept of causation and causation plays
a fundamental role in our normal picture
of mechanical interaction and if that's
right and this is now a good place to
end that's why David and I have been
more or less yelling at each other for a
couple decades is that when I hear
mechanical explanation I think in terms
of that kind of structure which seems to
me to already presuppose a direction of
time and if that's true then of course
there can't be a mechanical explanation
of the direction of time it's something
that already is sitting there in place
when you go about trying to provide
mechanical explanations of anything else
in that sense of mechanical all right so
that's where I've always had this kind
of cognitive dissonance in what it could
mean to produce a mechanical explanation
of the direction of times I think it's
one of the presuppositions now again if
you ask me okay why start there wow do
we know where to begin and where to end
how do we know what to take for granted
and what to explain in terms of it I'm
not giving you a general story I don't
have a general large-scale algorithm but
I think the sorts of considerations that
have come out in this case and they
actually only come out when you switch
your mathematics from the standard
mathematics to this different
mathematics I've been developing they
make a kind of compelling case right I
mean the whole idea of directionality
first of all arises in this mathematics
without any thought of time when I did
this I wasn't even thinking about time
once you think in terms of lines the
idea that the lines could be directed
could have a directionality just is
there it's sitting there and once you
take advantage of it you see there are a
bunch of geometries that you can
describe that are intrinsically directed
geometries and the standard way of doing
this just doesn't give you that
all right the standard T'Pau there the
standard topology if you open a standard
topology book
and you look for when is a standard
topology intrinsically directed you will
not find it in the index now I can
define it for you right I can tell you a
standard topology at least a that's a
sufficient condition a standard topology
is intrinsically directed if you can
derive it from a directed linear
structure and you can't derive it from
an undirected linear structure so I can
give you a definition standard topology
doesn't have it
so directedness the idea of directedness
just isn't an easy thing to get your
hands on mathematically using the
standard tools it arises naturally in
this way and then when you apply it to
physics now an another funny thing
happens you apply it to relativistic
physics and it just fits relativistic
physics like a glove it actually doesn't
give you the foliation x' that David
wanted it gives you light cone
structures instead right what you
naturally generate are light cone
structures and the fundamental thing
that's doing all the work is this basic
asymmetry of ordered nough sand time by
the before and after the relation so
that was the way i want to think about
this stuff i guess i actually I thought
I was done but all right this is what I
just said but that was ok that was the
last thank you